>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Joan Weeks: I'd like to
welcome you to the African
and Middle East Division
at the Library of Congress
and to our noontime lecture series
with today's program entitled
the Sultan's Gift, Book Diplomacy
in the Hamidian Period by Guy Burak.
And it's sponsored by the Near
East section of the African
and Middle East Division.
I'm Joan Weeks, I'm head
of the Near East section
and the Turkish specialist.
And on behalf of all my colleagues
and especially Dr. Mary Jane Deeb,
chief of the division, she
may join us in a little bit
with some of our guests today.
I'd like to extend a very
warm welcome to everyone.
But before we start today's program
and introduce our speaker I'd
like to give you a brief overview
of our division and its resources.
I know many of you've heard
this before many times,
but we also have some
visitors with us.
In the hopes that you'll come back
and use our beautiful reading
room for your research.
This division is comprised
of three sections that build
and serve the collections to
researchers from around the world.
We cover 75 countries and
more than two dozen languages.
The Africa section covers all of
the countries of sub-Saharan Africa.
The Hebraic section is responsible
for Judaica and Hebraica worldwide.
And the Near East section covers
all of the Arab countries,
including North Africa, Turkey,
Turkic Central Asia, Iran,
Afghanistan, the Muslims in western
China, Russia and the Balkans,
and the peoples of the Caucasus.
After the program we invite
you to fill in the little forms
that you see, our little survey.
We'd like to know how the program
-- what you liked about the program.
And you can leave these
forms at the reference desk
at the back in the little container.
And we'd also like to invite you
to ask questions during our program
after this, but this
program is being videotaped.
So if you ask questions you're
implicitly giving your permission
for us to be recorded.
Now I'd like to introduce
our speaker.
Guy Burak is the Middle Eastern
and Islamic studies librarian
at New York University,
Elmer Holmes Library.
He is the author of The Second
Formation of Islamic Law,
it was published by Cambridge
University Press in 2015.
And he publishes regularly on
Ottoman and Islamic history.
He did his PhD at NYU on
Ottoman legal history and was
in the Islamic legal studies
program at Harvard University.
He began working at NYU on February
2013, so he's a relatively newcomer.
But he seems to do it all reference,
acquisitions, and cataloging.
And one of his many projects at NYU
and his most recent endeavors
involves cataloguing the Abdul Hamid
collections at NYU.
And this is a very special
collection that was presented
by Abram Hewitt to the
Library of Congress.
We've got over almost 400
books, it has also been a gift
to the British Library, as
well as to New York University.
So without further ado I'll
let Guy Barak tell us all
about that collection
and his work with it.
Thank you.
>> Guy Burak: And good afternoon,
I have notes but I just speak.
And thank you Joan for the
invitation to be here, to talk
and share with you and my
experience with this project.
And it has been and it is a real
pleasure to be at the Library
of Congress in general and
specifically to be here
with this project that I have
been working on for quite a while.
And it's very much a work
in progress and I hope
that it will be the beginning
of a conversation between NYU
and the Library of Congress and
possibly many other libraries
about this collection and
what we can do with this
and similar collections that
we have in our institutions.
So this all started -- this
collection has a very long history
and I'll tell you a little
bit about in a few minutes.
And my history with this
connection is very, very recent.
A year ago or slightly more than a
year ago I got an e-mail from Hamid
and Waleed from the British
Library and he asked me
about do you know something
about the books that NYU received
from Abdulhamid the Second.
And I hadn't heard
about these books,
I mean I'm monotonous I did
my PhD at NYU, no one told me
about these things, I didn't know.
And so I contacted our
university archivist, Janet Bunde.
In general, I should say that
this is a collaborative project
with the university archives at
NYU and the special collections.
So I should mention my colleagues
Janet Bunde from the archives
and Charlotte Priddle from
the special collections.
They've all been extremely
supportive and helpful and in fact,
instrumental in this project.
So I contact Janet and ask her do
you know nothing about these books
or do you know anything
about these gifts?
Are there documents in the archive?
And a few days later she
came back and said yes,
actually we have things
in the accession books
and these are accession books
and these are the entries
in the accession books.
And at that time we thought
-- we just assumed okay,
we have the accession books, we
know that we received the books,
but we probably lost them
in one of the renovations
since the 19th century,
the late 19th century
when we received the books.
So we just -- but we also
found from the accession books
that we received the books
through Abram Hewitt.
So basically, there are two
main protagonists to this story.
One is obviously of
Abdulhamid the Second
and perhaps the most famous
sultan of the 19 century,
definitely the second
half of the 19th century.
And the second was Abram S. Hewitt.
At the time he was
the representative
and New York's representative
to the house.
And later he became
the mayor of New York.
Apparently at that
time Abdulhamid thought
that he would become the
President of the United States,
what actually did not happen.
But in 1884 Hewitt visited
Istanbul and had several meetings
with Abdulhamid the Second.
And in one of these meetings Hewitt
presented with this collection,
with the collection that
the Library of Congress have
and the collection that we have.
Interestingly, in 1940 Hewitt's
son wrote a very interesting piece
for the New Yorker and I'm
also grateful for Janet
for pointing this out to me.
And the piece is titled
The Sultan's Gift
and this is the piece
from the New Yorker.
And it actually tells some
very interesting stories,
very interesting details
about this collection.
And we hear the numbers
and Hewitt's son says
that his father received 395
books from Abdulhamid the Second.
He also says that when
Hewitt came back
to the US he sent Abdulhamid
some gilded pens
and 10,000 Virginia cigarettes.
So it's a very cool piece
if you have time you should actually
take the time and take a look at it.
But so that was the
first clue we had.
Then a few days ago, less
than a week ago actually,
Professor [inaudible]
from Boston University
who actually has seen the set
at NYU sent me this document.
This is a document from the Ottoman
archives talking about the gift.
It was issued by the [inaudible],
the Ministry of Education
or something along those lines.
And what is interesting
in this story --
from this document is that it
completely changed my perception,
not completely, but it changed my
perception of history of the gift.
Before I saw this document I assumed
that Hewitt received one set,
gave it to the Library of Congress
and then Abdulhamid was so excited
by the reception or
by the enthusiasm
that he gave Hewitt a second set.
And for some reason apparently
because he didn't want
to pay taxes he gave
this collection to NYU.
But this document tells
a very different story.
This document apparently Hewitt
was presented with two sets,
one from what they call the American
[inaudible] that is the Library
of Congress and the second
was a personal set or a set
that was intended to be or to be a
personal set for Monsieur Hewitt.
It actually describes
what you Abdulhamid wanted
to do with the books.
He specifically explains
how they should be bound
and how they should be inscribed.
He also said -- we also learned
from this document the
scope of this collection.
Basically, it's the connection
should include all the books
that were published presumably
in Istanbul or in the core lands
of the empire from Abdulhamid's
accession to the throne in 1876.
There are two copies
of this document.
This is one, this is the second
and they were issued in 1884,
the same date when the books
were actually given to Hewitt.
So this is how the books look
like and one of the things
that is actually interesting
about the NYU set is
that it remained pretty much intact.
I mean some books are in
better shapes than others.
But we still have the physical books
bound and I think that the Library
of Congress have two or three
books that remained intact.
But we still have the
physical object
and they are extremely brittle and
the paper is incredibly acidic,
especially the books
published in Arabic.
I don't know why were
printed on a much better paper
and I don't have a good
explanation why this is the case,
but this is how it is.
And so among the -- so, so far
at NYU we have catalogued mostly the
Turkish or the Ottoman Turkish part
and we are about or we
just started working
on the Persian and the Arabic.
And most of the collection out
of the 400 titles in our books
in Ottoman and the rest are
in Persian and in Arabic.
So for the Ottoman collection you
can find books by the usual suspects
or what I call the usual suspects.
Books by Ahmed Cevdet Pasha,
the famous jurist and scholar
and also a Ministry of Justice
and an incredibly important
reformer of the 19th century.
So we have most of his
works in this collection,
including the recently published
the Mecelle, [inaudible],
the Ottoman Legal Code published
in the mid 60's or the late 60's.
There are also books by Ahmed
Midhat Efendi, the famous author
and novelist of the
19th century who was one
of his works was recently
published --
a translation of one of his work
was recently published in English.
So this is how a book by
Midhat Efendi looks like.
What is interesting
about these books
and this actually raises some
questions, cataloguing questions
because the books, the
collection, what is very interesting
about the collection even if
the books are well-known is
that it raises some interesting
questions about the book,
the history of the book in
the early Hamidian period.
And some of the questions that
we are confronted when we see,
I mean those title pages raise
some very interesting questions
in terms of cataloguing.
So for instance, there was
this very interesting practice
that you had the publisher,
but then or a printer,
but then a publisher
bought the printed books
and just stamped them like this.
So it's not part of the title page
and for most part most
records have tended
to take the printer
as the publisher.
But there we have this interesting
practice and they're all kind
of practices that we see when we
look at this collection closely.
And because I'm not an expert
in Hamidian book history,
so I still don't know what to
do with these practices and how
to reflect them in our records.
But I just thought it would be
interesting to point this out.
There are also quite a few
translations from a wide range
of languages from Russian to
French to English and German.
This is a translation of
Alexandre Dumas [inaudible],
but we have a very wide range
of books, mostly novels,
but also military manuals published
in the early Hamidian period.
There are also quite
a few lithographs.
Most of the books are movable and
were printed using movable type,
but there are quite
a few lithographs.
And what is interesting
about those lithographs is
that they are usually books
that are almost ephemera.
They are textbooks, they
are manuals for engineers
and railroad builders
and all those things.
And I should say that this it's nice
because it supplements
a very nice collection
of lithographs that we have at NYU.
And covering lithographs
basically from the [inaudible]
to the Indian subcontinent.
So this collection fills
a very interesting gap
that we have in our collection.
But the most interesting thing
about the collection is
not the famous works.
One of the interesting things
and it was a bit puzzling
when we started going through the
boxes is that we realized that most
of the collection or not most,
but there are quite a few titles
that are almost ephemera.
And this one for example is a
very small book that was done
for the commanders of small
military units in the Hamidian Army
or the Hamidian Military.
There are also all kind of annual
statistics of the court system,
cookbooks, there are textbooks
intended for different students
in different stages of the
Ottoman or the Hamidian curriculum.
And I think that there are the
most interesting and rare books
that we got for this collection.
And these things have not been --
obviously, they were not purchased
in the 19th century and if they were
they were never taken seriously.
So it's a way of getting very --
it offers a glimpse into
the less prestigious sides
of the Hamidian book
culture of the first,
at least for the first
decade of Abdulhamid's rule.
So and this is the most interesting
thing for this talk I think.
One of the interesting things is
to figure out who has those sets.
So we know that the Library of
Congress has a set and we know
that NYU has a set, apparently the
British Museum has a set and we know
that the British Library has a set.
Apparently, Leiden or some
Dutch university have a set,
I mean I say it based on
the records I found on OCLC.
They seem to have most
of the records.
So they may have gotten
these through a similar gift.
So if someone in the Netherlands
is watching this show or this talk,
please contact me I'd be very glad
to know if they have a similar set.
But my assumption or
the assumption I had
when we catalogued these books is
that there are many
more sets out there.
I might be wrong, but when we
catalogued the set our assumption
was or what we wanted to do,
we wanted to create records
that other libraries could use
to identify similar
sets in their holdings.
I should also point out that
we got this set in a moment
in the scholarship where
there is a renewed interest
in Ottoman book culture in
general and specifically,
in the book culture of
the Hamidian period.
These are three studies that I know
of and that were published recently
about Hamidian, about the history
of the book and the Hamidian period.
I should just point out that
[inaudible] article studies the
connections between a specific
publisher that he's well-represented
in the set and Abdulhamid
during the Hamidian period.
And one of the things that
we want to do or at least
that we hope the set will allow
is to do more studies like this.
Look at the publisher, so
that scholars could look
at the different publishers and
see what we can learn from the sets
that are in the collection or from
the books that are in the collection
about the connections
between these publishers
and Abdulhamid and his court.
And one of these things
is what we try to do is
that through the metadata
to create --
we use those studies to see
what scholars are looking
for when they are studying Hamidian
book culture and we are trying
to respond to these questions and
to these needs in our metadata.
And I'll say a few words
about it in a few minutes.
So this is how the
records look like.
I'll just say that one of the
questions that we've been trying
to figure out is how
to transliterate the Ottoman
titles this is I think a question
that everyone who is
cataloguing Ottoman materials is
struggling with.
I'll say that for the most
part if records existed
in OCLC we didn't change
[inaudible] system
because we didn't want
OCLC to reject our records.
But we did add Arabic
script to all the fields.
So this is one of the records
of the book that actually came
from the Library of Congress and
we also kept the call numbers
or at least this was [inaudible]
collection call number.
We have 15 of these so far I think.
And this is how the
record looks like.
We included a description
of the physical books
and the most important we obviously
added all the basic fields.
We added 2796 that we are in
the process of transforming
into 700 fields for both Abram
Hewitt and Abdulhamid the Second
so that users can actually
go through the collection
and have a sense of the
set in its entirety.
And when we created or generated
original records we followed the
Library of Congress
Ottoman [inaudible] system.
I know it's not a common practice,
but we thought it would be nice.
We also added Arabic script and
something that is not very common
in cataloguing of Ottoman
materials for two reasons.
The first reason is that Arabic
script enables users to search
across the three main
Ottoman languages.
It's very frustrating to figure
out the transliteration is
in Turkish, in modern Turkish.
And this is particularly important
because many of these books
that were translated into Ottoman
in that time period
were also translated
into Arabic in Egypt or Beirut.
So it will be nice to have --
so we wanted users to
have the searchability
across the Ottoman language divides.
But the other reason
is that we assume
or at least there is
this possibility
that a similar set was
given to other libraries
in what is today Middle
Eastern countries.
It is possible that similar sets
exist in Egypt and maybe in Iran
and we thought that it would
be useful for whoever will look
at these records in these
countries to have the Arabic
that might make the
integration of these records
into the catalogue easier.
And I'll also show you how it
looks like if you want to look
at the collection in its entirety.
That's based on the 796 field
for Abdulhamid the Second.
So here you have all the books
that we have catalogued so far
and eventually we hope that
people could actually browse
through the collection and
find interesting titles based
on Abdulhamid.
I want to conclude
by saying a few words
about what we hope
will be the next step.
So first, we hope to complete
the processing of this collection
by the end of the summer and
make it available to researchers
with a brief description
and analysis of what's there
so users will know about it.
And we may digitize, especially
the ephemera selectively
because these are things that
we hope or assume will be --
maybe heavily used is a
strong, is too hopeful,
but they will be used more
than the famous works.
And because they are brittle,
so it would make sense
to actually have them digitized.
And finally, we hope
to publish the records
so other libraries could use it.
And we might use it as a way
to experiment with link data
and to think about
different RDF environments.
So far as far as I know very
little has been worked --
very little has been done with
RDF in special collections
to trace provenance and to
link collections in terms
of where the books came from.
And that might be an interesting way
and I really hope that the Library
of Congress will be interested
in using these records
and experimenting with them
as part of their big frame,
the development of big frame.
And we also hope that other
institutions will use these records
to have a better understanding of
the history of their collections
and about this practice
of giving books
in the Hamidian and
the Ottoman period.
And I think I'll stop here.
[ Applause ]
>> Joan Weeks: Thank
you very much Guy.
I'd like to invite questions
and please know again
that you're being recorded
if you're asking questions.
But a fascinating presentation
I'm sure some
of our [inaudible] must
have some questions
and Guy will answer
those questions for us.
Anybody, questions?
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Guy Burak: So that's something
that we don't really know
who made the selection.
The description says that all
the books that were published
in I don't know if in the empire
since 1876 were included
in this gift.
Obviously, this is not the case
because there are no books in Greek,
Armenian, Hebrew and so
these are mostly books
in Arabic, Turkish and Persian.
And probably and they don't include
books that were published as far
as we can tell, they don't
include books published
in the Arab provinces
and even in the provinces
in Anatolia and in the Balkans.
There are a few books that
were published in provinces
that are pretty close to Istanbul,
but we don't really know
who decided to include.
I mean there might be
other documents out there.
But if someone comes
across something
that would be really,
really interesting.
But we also know that
there are some differences
between the collection
not major differences.
Apparently we have some titles that
the Library of Congress do not have.
But once we have the inventories so
we can actually compare holdings.
>> Thank you very much for
your presentation it was
fascinating [inaudible].
>> Guy Burak: I didn't know about
the photograph, I mean I knew --
by the photograph you
mean the famous album?
>> Yes.
>> Guy Burak: We didn't
get the famous album.
I think the famous album exists only
two copies in the world or I think,
so we just got the books.
I don't know the albums well enough
to say how we can actually link
or what kind of links
could be established
between these collections.
And I think they are part of
the same interest of Abdulhamid
in projecting a certain
image of the empire.
Although, I've recently
heard there are some doubts
about who was behind the album
and how officially it was done.
But yeah, I mean in
terms of if there are --
I mean I don't know them well
enough, but if someone can think
of interesting connections I'd be
more than happy to talk about it.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Joan Weeks: I put
you on the spot but.
>> Okay [inaudible] photographs
division we do have the photographic
albums that were given
to the library.
We couldn't bring them today
because they're quite fragile
and we don't serve
them to researchers.
We have digital images of all
the photographs in the album.
They were done a while ago,
so they don't really reflect the
quality of the actual images.
But this is a handout that we have
that shows what the covers look like
and some information about it.
So there is an individual
catalogue record and image
for every photograph
that is in the --
and I'm not remember how
many albums there are.
So you can see it online
and we have information
about the website where
you can find them.
And if you come to the
reading room we do have a few
that are safely housed
and in certain circumstances we
will show them to researchers.
Are there any questions
about the albums?
I'd be glad to.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Guy Burak: Sure
that would be amazing.
>> It would be interesting to see.
>> Guy Burak: I mean if they're good
it would be -- I mean in general,
I mean what is or at least what
I thought would be interesting is
to have a sense of what's out there
knowing that we have only part
of the Hamidian production, but
that people could actually add
to this collection and
eventually we'll have a sense
of what was published in the
empire and in this time period.
And what was given as gifts to
different libraries in Europe,
North America, and possibly
the Middle East and beyond.
And the albums are obviously an
important part of it and I'd be more
than happy to collaborate with
whoever has records and collections.
And again, this is one of
the reasons why we think --
we are thinking seriously
about publishing the records.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes, I mean.
Yeah, I'll start with the
second because it's easier
or at least I haven't gone through
the entire Persian collection.
Most of the things
are in the [inaudible]
with some have commentaries,
some don't.
But as far as I can tell at
this point are mostly classics.
I might be wrong there might be
things that I haven't seen yet.
The assumption is that most of these
books exist somewhere in Turkey
and the main problem is it's
mostly a discoverability issue.
It's very difficult to find
records for these books,
at least on the platforms that
we are using or not in OCLC
and if they are not they
are not English records.
So this is -- but we do hope, I mean
I know that some Turkish scholars
and Turkish librarians have
been or have shown interest
in this collection and I think
that once it's done people will --
I hope it will draw more attention
and people will in Turkey and again,
else will actually go
back to their libraries
and look at their holdings.
But so far many of these books
I've not been able to find
in Turkish libraries, but to
be fair I haven't been looking
at the catalogues of
individual libraries.
But I assume they are there.
>> Joan Weeks: [Inaudible]
anymore questions?
No? Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Guy Burak: I mean the collection
when I started cataloguing
it seems incredibly random.
You have everything from
cookbooks to engineering manuals
to school textbooks
to military manuals
to high classics to Islamic law.
It's a very, very wide -- it's
a very wide range of topics.
And I think that this is one of the
things that makes this collection
so interesting is precisely
because it was not --
it didn't focus on the
high note or the classics,
but it actually gave
everything or not everything,
but that he gave Hewitt most of
what was published in Turkey,
as long as it was printed.
And this is why I think
the collection is
so riveting and interesting.
>> Joan Weeks: I'd like to show
you [inaudible] collection.
This is one of the books and
I want everybody to come up
and have a close-up look at this.
It's got a gold leaf on the
pages and the dedication
on the front cover it's made by his
Majesty Sultan Abdulhamid the Second
to the National Library of
the United States of America
through the honorable A. S. Hewitt.
And it goes on through this and on
the back side I've turned second
from [inaudible] back side so that.
These are very, very
fragile, very brittle paper.
And I think that's why the library
microfilmed the entire collection
of books.
And the back side is all
in the Ottoman Turkish.
And I wanted to kind of ask I
noticed on your slide that one
of the entries was
for Susine [phonetic]
and Susine was this eclectic, I
call him almost a renaissance man
in this [inaudible]
Ottoman materials.
And I noticed you had an
entry there for Susine
and I don't know whether the
book happened to be the same book
that Susine collected,
probably that's what happened
because we've got the
catalogue in here [inaudible].
Alan Mayberry [inaudible]
the primary catalogue
of our collections, but I don't know
if there's some kind of parallel
that we have a Susine book
that replicates one of these.
I'd invite you to come up and
look at these upfront and personal
and also in the back
on our microfilm reader machine
I loaded a reel of the microfilm.
So in the 80's they
microfilmed our Library
of Congress entire collection.
This is what so intrigued
me when I met Guy Barak
at the Middle East
Librarians Associated
and started talking about this.
And I said well we've got the
microfilm for this collection
and I know one of the
most exciting things
that they're doing now
is digitizing microfilm.
And I can see such potential if you
could figure out which books are
which and digitize our
microfilm, digitize these records.
I think bit frame is a wave
of the future for cataloguing
because it links data, which
means that you can link
through to these photographic
albums,
you can link through to
other library's holdings,
knowledge of these collections
in hopes of tremendous potential.
So I invite you to come
around and look at the books
and we have pictures of what the
photographic albums look like.
Also if you want to
look at the microfilm
in the back machine
what that looks like.
We invite you to come in
and do research using the
microfilm, that's easy to surf.
And I hope you will come
back and really investigate
and help us process this
collection, so thank you.
>> Guy Burak: And I'll
just say that if you want
to use the physical books
you're more than welcome to NYU
to our special collections
library, the [inaudible] library
and they will live there.
And most of the collection
will be there and available
to the public hopefully
very, very soon.
That's it, thank you.
>> Joan Weeks: Thank you very much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.